hey guys this is Cameron with motion
science back with another quick tip /
trick for After Effects and this week I
am continuing the focus on the 3d camera
inside After Effects someone recently
asked me how I would make a 3d camera
follow a spiral path and it got me
thinking and I came up with two very
quick solutions to how to do that
so I'm gonna show you what those two
solutions are so to start off I'm going
to show you I've got my scene here I've
got a wide angle 24 millimeter camera
I've set up a grid in the background
some white circles and a couple lights
that are lighting them to show some
perspective you can't see all these
objects in the timeline because they are
shied to keep the timeline clean for you
so what I'm gonna do first is I'm going
to add to null objects 1 & 2 on the
second null object I'm going to shrink
the scale down to about 50% I'm going to
make both of these nulls 3d and you
could see over here the smaller null
inside the larger null so I'm going to
parent the smaller null to the larger
null and I'm going to create a rotation
with the large model on the z-axis so
I'll set a keyframe hit end on my
keyboard to go to the end of the
timeline and I'll set a second keyframe
for one full rotation 360 degrees I'm
also going to add a position keyframe
and for this I'm gonna move it back
about oh I don't know 1000 pixels or so
so I'll hit home on the keyboard to go
to the first keyframe and for the second
null hit P for positions set a keyframe
go to the end of the timeline and I'm
going to move the exposition forward
about 450 pixels
so you can see here that the first Knoll
is rotating while the second Knoll is
rotating with the first Knoll but moving
outwards so we've essentially created a
spiral now all we have to do is parent
our camera to the top Knoll and we've
got a spiral camera move the problem
with this solution is that you'll see
the camera spins and it kind of throws
the perspective off because of that well
because the first Knoll did a full one
rotation I can counteract that by
setting a keyframe of negative one so
now it'll appear that the camera does
not rotate at all to throw out the
perspective but we still get the spiral
motion so the great thing about this
solution is that we have full control
over how close the camera starts how
tight the spiral starts and then how
wide the spiral goes just by adjusting
our different keyframes here you know so
here I made the spiral go wider I might
want it to have more than one rotation
so I'll set it to two I'll counteract
that with a negative two on the camera
and I'll show you what that looks like
so here we've got just a larger spiral
camera move so I hope that this helps
and that you understand the principles
of what I just showed you here it's very
simple you can see in this window here
kind of what's going on as well so
that's solution number one so now let me
show you duplicate this and I'll make
solution number two I reset everything
okay so for solution number two we are
going to jump into illustrator and over
here and illustrator under the line
segment tool there's the spiral tool so
I'll do is click and drag and I've
created a spiral and I'm just selecting
that spiral hitting command C on the Mac
to copy or you can go up here to edit
copy jumping back into after-effects and
you can do this one of two ways the
easiest way is just to select the
position of the camera and hit command V
to paste and you can see here that the
spiral path is pasted onto the camera
now the first problem is that the
cameras shooting off over here the
reason for that is because this is a two
node camera if you switch it to one node
it goes right back to facing forward so
the other solution here is when you
whenever you paste a spiral it's gonna
guesstimate how far apart to space the
keyframes based on the curves of the
spiral the easy way is just to grab the
last keyframe and just drag it to
wherever you want it to end because
these are roving keyframes we're too
close here to see any of the circles but
a quick solution of that is to add
another null object make it 3d parent
the camera to that Knoll and just move
that an old back in z space to create
the back movement and Z to simulate our
spiral move same with where the null
begins okay so we can see these circles
here
and I can also select both keyframes by
just selecting position and I can move
them just like this so I can focus my
scene war on what I want to see okay so
this solution worked the circles are off
the screen a little bit too much and
you'll notice too that we are doing the
opposite move we're going from a wide
part of the spiral to the narrow part of
the spiral and the easy way to fix that
if I want to do the opposite move is
just to select all keyframes go to keep
em assistant time reverse and now we'll
start tight and go wide as you can see
over here I can reposition
okay so here's this solution starts
really tight and goes really wide so
again this solution looks pretty cool as
well but when I did start this solution
I told you there's one of two ways you
could do this so this was the first way
with pasting the path right into the
position of the camera another way to do
this is to create a new shape layer
convert to a path so it's just a
straight up path and then paste the file
spiral from illustrator into the path of
the shape layer the advantage to doing
it this way is that I have control over
if I want the path to be smaller or
larger so it's just a little more
flexibility in the size of the path that
the camera will take because what I can
do now is size it to how I think it's
appropriate copy from here and then copy
it into the position of the camera so
you can see here it's much smaller path
if I think if that doesn't quite work I
can enlarge it maybe just say here copy
again and paste the path is slightly
larger I want it really big sit like
that
copy/paste now it's a much larger path
so again the camera has gone back to a
two node camera switched back to one
node and there we go
so that's what I've got for you today I
know this was another quick one and I
kind of rushed through this but I hope
that you did learn something cool please
comment below like subscribe let me know
what you think if you have suggestions
for future quick tutorials let me know I
love to hear from you guys so until next
time I'm Cameron and this is motion
science